all right in other news tonight there
are reports that Trump's legal team has
preparing has been repairing to hand
over written answers to Muller's team
joining us now live from Washington on
this and much more Fox News chief
intelligence correspondent our own
Catherine Herridge that sounds like we
might be getting to the end Catherine
well that's right Sean and good evening
to sources familiar with the discussions
told Fox tonight the written answers are
being finalized and could be submitted
to the special counsel robert muller and
his team as early as the end of this
week contacted by fox the president's
lawyers had no immediate comment we
recently reported the president's legal
team was preparing written responses
about alleged coordination with russia
during the 2016 campaign and non
obstruction of justice over the
president's may 2017 firing of FBI
director james comey the president's
legal team considers those questions
infringed on the president's
constitutional power to hire and fire
returning to Capitol Hill earlier today
Democrats also ramped up attacks on
Matthew Whitaker the acting Attorney
General with the Senate Judiciary
Committee's ranking Democrat Dianne
Feinstein calling for emergency hearings
with Whitaker and former attorney
general Jeff Sessions the committee's
Republican chairman who controls the
Senate committee calendar and knows
Whitaker from Iowa politics pointed to
the ongoing Justice Department ethics
review so I think that answers that
doesn't matter what the Democrats think
if he's going through that process
that's going to answer that
about the comments that Whitaker is made
about the molar protein also as long as
he made them as long as he made him as a
private citizen not sources familiar
with the process
tell Fox's Justice Department's Office
of Legal Counsel plans to issue an
opinion defending the Whitaker
appointment and pushing back strongly
against legal analysis that the
appointment is unconstitutional sources
said the opinion is expected in the
coming days possibly as early as
tomorrow Sean all right Catherine
Herridge was an important reports and I
thank you